i think a lot of people who uh who end
up being a fan of sound money in general
right
they basically look at the macro system
today and they say hey we're printing a
bunch of money
whether it's bitcoin or gold you're
going to see those things
increase in u.s dollar value we're
devaluing the dollar and obviously those
things are going to increase
in value um there's people in the gold
community that say oh the
the solution to this is to go back to a
gold standard right
i tend to think uh unlikely that that
will happen although i understand the
argument
what's more likely is that every fiat
currency in the world just digitizes so
you get a digital dollar digital euro
digital yen
you know one all the way through and
then you basically don't have
competition at the
technology layer because now whether
it's bitcoin it's a private currency
like libra it's
a digital dollar it's all digitized and
where the competition plays out is at
the monetary policy level
is that in line i know that you've done
a bunch of work on the digital dollar
and in the blockchain caucus and kind of
all of that work but just
how are you guys thinking about digital
dollar bitcoin libra
and kind of where that competition plays
out well
so uh two things first you talked about
devaluing the dollar
i'm going to suggest to you that there
may be people here in washington right
now
that really think they can play with
this funny money all the way through the
end of the year and they can continue to
print trillions of dollars
because they'll say two things one well
we'll just devalue the dollar
and when you complain about it you know
what their answer is yeah but our
exports i mean people buy a lot more
stuff
that's not the answer pomp that's not
monetary policy
that's greed that's just uh you know and
that's also just kicking the can down
the road for tomorrow
um but the digital dollar first off
i i don't like the idea
of uh every country and that's what
we're looking at
i mean i can tell you that the bankers
that i work with good guys
one of my colleagues has really done
some work since we got here
on getting up to speed on uh on this
cryptocurrency area and what it means
and he's a traditional banker
and he did not start with that with that
view
but i don't think he'd go where i want
to go and where i want to go is
you're not going to get competition if
you
turn it over to the government you're
gonna get what they see in china
okay because remember pop somebody
has to be in control i prefer that if
we're doing a
uh if we're working at cryptocurrency
you're in control of your wallet i'm in
control of my wallet and you and i
are doing the exchange between us
because i don't need big brother one
watching what we're doing uh two i don't
need
and i know this whole bit about uh know
your customer
and that's just gone way overboard
that's
you can become a prisoner of your own
safety and security and that is what
we've done
we just keep putting up these we got
more people that come in
and you know it's like we have to do
this because
you know what pomp is gonna the chinese
are gonna do this to them or they're
gonna steal whatever or
this uh terrorist group uh no
no i don't think so um i
i just don't see it and while there is
uh a place for it again you can probably
tell
i tend to to not my view
by the way i'm in the minority at this
point
i'm in the minority what would it take
for
a single state so we saw the state of
ohio for example the treasurer's office
said hey
we're gonna accept bitcoin for taxes uh
when that treasurer transitioned out it
basically was reversed almost
immediately
right yeah i joked with josh mandel
who's the treasurer who did it
i said it was like a one-man show who
got something through and then the
second he walked out of the room
everyone you know rearranged the room
back to how it was before what would it
take in
your state or another state to really
kind of
adopt some of this stuff as a second
currency is that something that has to
have buy-in across
kind of everywhere from the local all
the way up to the state is that a state
you know top-down thing like how does
that work oh i think it's going to have
to come from the bottom up
i and it's actually both ways right and
i'm just looking because we've got a
bill
that we did on state licensing
i think it starts with stuff like that
it might seem not very sexy right
uh but wait a second if the federal
government
creates a one-size-fits-all when you're
dealing with uh the exchange of uh
crypto and you now don't have to get a
money transmitting license in every
single state and then they start
uh micromanaging because you got people
in those offices that don't know what's
going on
so you create that that type of stuff
one
will allow it will take away the 50
state patchwork right in the in the in
the district
uh that will help but then you're going
to have to have pressure from the bottom
and the pressure from the bottom we've
got talent
right i and we've got uh capital
that will one both leave this country
they will go find a place for this to
work the dollar
or the bitcoin will always follow the
path of least resistance
so if we want to be behind the eight
ball which we already are in some cases
we can continue to let this go the
second thing is
once you start doing money transmitter
license bills once you have
uh brian brooks what he did last week by
allowing
uh banks to to uh to actually bank the
uh
uh take custody of crypto assets
what he did there that signal
really gets the ball rolling now we got
a problem with
maybe the secretary of the treasury
maybe you know
a former sec adviser our
secretary whatever you call them
chairman
but you've got a lot of people and it's
growing on the inside of these
institutions
and that's why brian brooks i met with
him a few weeks ago and just
so grateful that they put him there
right
but it has to pick up momentum because
here's the other thing
and you work with the people in this
area a lot more than i do
i get to meet them they're interesting i
mean i love the ones that go out
and start a trading platform that's
worth millions
and they never graduated from ufc but
guess what
usc invites them back because they want
to give them an honorary degree and have
them talk to their students that are
paying an exorbitant amount
for a worthless education much of the
time you know it's that old
how much do you spend for your college
education uh
250 000 and what's your daughter doing
welcome to arby's can i take your order
um but the uh i think
once it it starts to roll and you get
the pressure
here here's the other thing i'll leave
it with this you got really smart
young people in this area they're going
to figure out a way to get around the
rules
this is where i i've said this in other
places
this is where the roman empire went when
the citizens didn't know and didn't care
for years
that the government had actually fallen
i mean think about it was it spain just
a couple years ago
they didn't have a government for over a
year and their economy was actually
improving
huh that's a head scratcher not really
so it's people that you're interviewing
all the time it's people that you're
intersecting and interacting with
they're going to figure out how to do
this and government can actually
help facilitate it and then make sure
you know
where and i think the community is the
best to help us with this
where we need to lean in right where
there are dangers where there are bad
guys where there are
the thing that bothers me the most and
sorry it just triggered me when i said
bad guys
it seemed at the beginning like all of
my colleagues democrat and republican
alike
every time you mentioned bitcoin or
crypto they all they heard was silk road
that's why bringing up twitter i'm very
grateful of because
they did it again right it wasn't
bitcoin it caused the problem it was
twitter
and it's it's like every time there's
this
maybe it's because of the name maybe
crypto just gives it a bad
you know there's something bad going on
there it's cryptic